race day i got the quickest horses i got
the quickest feet
like i'm from the country too you know i
can ride horses too you know
one of the top fastest the quickest
receivers in the league but
today i prove i'm the quickest
mother boy's in trouble he got his own
horse probably under 40 with his horse
the quicker pick has arrived
i'm in miami this is great weather gonna
run a 40-yard dash
beautiful day to be quick i'm not
worrying about my competition at all
i ain't never seen a cheater stretch
before they just get up and run
[Music]
y'all lucky i'm not running on the field
let's go baby
let's go it's going that way
[Music]
you know i'll take it four three seven
let's get it let's get it
hey i know that's the one right there i
know that's the one
yes sir four two six the clock don't lie
four two two as quick the quickest you
don't
ever see drop the clock on them yeah
i'm out of here ah
shut out the bounty for putting this 40
time together for
me and the guys unfortunately i wasn't
the quickest pick today but
you got to race me side by side shout
out to the quicker picker upper
i'm excited to be out here and be the
quicker pick like i knew i could be
i proved on the field that's what i did
the quickest quicker
than anybody that came out here but i
had fun i enjoyed it shout out to bounty
for putting on this
for charity um can't thank them enough
for doing what they doing
and again i'm a quicker pick salute